[Musique]
par conséquent soeur pour des rh le drh
en voit tous ces paramètres dans le
petit corner en parlant après une fois
tout est enregistré
il fait fonctionner la machine il a un
bouton test qui lui permet de voir si
tout va bien et est pris en compte lors
de la réflexion et bien non ça va dans
le rouge tête de mort ça ne fonctionnera
pas elle sert juste à démontrer qu'on ne
prend jamais en compte avant de prendre
une décision
dans une entreprise il est très sérieux
le concepteur de cette drôle de machine
quand il en explique le fonctionnement
bienvenue dans l'univers d'eric geffroy
un monde plein d'humour et de poésie
un brin loufoque aussi
[Musique]
son atelier est un laboratoire insolites
des instruments de mesure fantaisistes
comme cette machine à sonder la
générosité des sculptures musicales
investir industriel avec ses 50 nuance
de mouches
l'artiste est sculpteur par assemblage
il crée des objets avec d'autres objets
récupérés chez les ferrailleurs
ça va du manot m là où blocs moteurs
c'est vrai que dans un tas de rebut mon
oeil va se poser sur certains objets
écarter complètement tous les goûts il
ya des objets surprenants comme ça qui
font sourire aujourd'hui qu'ils portent
en eux jade l'humour puis nous ramène
des fois des contextes de vie de métier
de vie domestique somme ça ça ça
m'intéresse découvert j'ai découvert des
objets comme ça c'est surprenant de des
tirs poils de nez
j'ai trouvé ça dans une ferrari en
argent qui était mis dans une poche et
puis est bas les limites si cet objet je
peux lui faire raconter notre histoire
il continuera sa vie avec moi
eric geffroy et un raconteur d'histoires
avec autre chose que des mots il en
appelle à l'imagination de chacun
petits et grands
[Musique]